au fond ce que le président de la
République essaie de faire si vous vous
replacez dans une perspective historique
c'est à peu près ce que tous ces
prédécesseurs depuis longtemps essaie de
faire aussi c'est-à-dire d'inventer une
nouvelle diplomatie française qui soit
adapté à la réalité économique politique
financière de la France de surcroît dans
le contexte européen et au fond la vraie
rupture elle est par rapport à ce que
nous étions avant la deuxième guerre
mondiale une une puissance
certains diront colonial mais enfin un
empire un des grands empires européens
qui s'est retrouvé après la deuxième
guerre mondiale
regardez les défaites en Indochine la
crise de Suède la guerre d'Algérie la
France se retrouvait
avec la nécessité de trouver une
nouvelle diplomatie adaptée à ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui non c'est une puissance
en clair voilà le général de Gaulle a
essayé à sa manière c'est lui qui
[Musique]
d'abord on a plus le choix puisque
la puissance française a changé on est
une puissance moyenne mais on a une
puissance moyenne forte qui a des atouts
avec un statut particulier le statut
c'est important puisqu'on est permanent
du Conseil de sécurité même si
aujourd'hui il est paralysé mais
ce sont des voies qui comptent un peu
plus dans le monde on a l'arme nucléaire
aussi et c'est important et nous sommes
les seuls indépendants à cet égard en
Europe puisque justement le choix
s'était fait au moment de Suez qui vient
d'être évoqué la conclusion des
Britanniques c'est bon on a échoué on
est plus une grande puissance mais donc
on va coller davantage au Britannique
aux Américains pardon et la conclusion
française est bien il faut qu'on soit
indépendant doux effectivement
l'arme nucléaire et cette volonté
toujours d'être indépendant et de ne pas
être aligné sur une puissance le mot
d'ordre ça a toujours été allié mais non
alignés ce qui fait que on sera lié aux
États-Unis quand il y avait une crise
majeure comme bon les eaux missiles Cuba
avec l'Union soviétique mais là le
problème va se poser très rapidement
dans le cadre de du conflit entre les
États-Unis et la Chine si on veut
exister il faut effectivement être une
puissance d'équilibre alors le président
la répéter pas d'équidistance mais il
n'empêche qu'on cherche quand même une
troisième fois
équilibre sans équidistance dans un
monde où le multilatéralisme était en
crise aiguë Thomas Gomart vous vous
mettez du contenu dans cette formulation
de de puissance partenariale de
confiance
un peu plus dans cette deuxième
formulation que dans la formulation de
puissance d'équilibre avec un S que
jamais très bien comprise pour être tout
à fait honnête
parce que cette idée de troisième voie
me semble assez illusoire pour tout dire
dans la mesure où elle porte l'idée
qu'au fond il y aurait une voix
américaine une voix chinoise et puis une
voix incarnée par la France mais pour
être leader il faut des followers donc
on a parfois l'impression que cette
troisième voie c'est aussi peut-être
l'expression d'un isolement en
particulier mon sens en Europe ce qui
m'a frappé moi dans le discours du
président de la République c'est le peu
d'attention portait à l'Europe en
réalité par rapport à d'autres sujets à
un moment où on a quand même une
question assez fondamentale sur le
fonctionnement de la relation
franco-allemande
en particulier liée à la lecture que les
deux capitales ont pu faire de la guerre
d'Ukraine avant qu'elle ne reprenne en
février 2022 je suis plus à l'aise avec
la notion de puissance de confiance
parce qu'effectivement je pense qu'il y
a une position diplomatique française
traditionnelle qui est de pouvoir parler
avec tout le monde et de vouloir le
faire ce qui est pas le cas d'autres
d'autres Européens sont toujours être
très capables de former des vrais
partenariats oui mais effectivement
toujours un peu avec nos solutions ça
revient quand même pierre et mon indiqué
je pense qu'il y a quand même une
compréhension de la nouvelle géographie
du monde et de partenariats avec des
pays comme je sais pas je pense à
l'Indonésie ça c'est très ancré et puis
moi la puissance de confiance ça me fait
penser aussi les jeunes aujourd'hui
disent il faut prendre la confiance et
je pense que parfois effectivement on a
besoin sur la scène internationale d'une
France qui se saisisse d'un sujet et qui
essaie de faire bouger d'autres
Européens parfois un peu statique et on
le fait assez selon vous faut pas trop
le faire faut le faire quand on a des
chances de succès d'accord Renault
Girard qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
cette
on l'a fait c'était un des grands
moments de la diplomatie française mon
amour créé on a montré du jugement et de
l'indépendance d'esprit c'est très
important
c'est lorsque nous sommes opposés et
nous sommes un peu seul au Conseil de
sécurité justement à l'intervention
américaine en Irak et
poussé par Jacques Chirac Dominique de
Villepin mais bien expliqué dans son
fameux discours de février 2003 que les
Américains allaient à la catastrophe et
qu'il fallait surtout pas intervenir
utiliser le hard power
et alors on était soutenu par un peu par
l'Allemagne mais par exemple la Russie
les chinoise les Chinois n'ont pas
beaucoup parlé c'est plus facile de
s'opposer que de bâtir voilà autre chose
alors nous avons eu raison l'histoire
nous avons eu raison mais on a fait une
erreur après c'est à dire que nous
avions
convaincu le monde entier que le
néoconservatisme cette idée qu'on allait
imposer la démocratie par la force à
d'autres peuples
ça ne pouvait pas fonctionner mais
malheureusement nous avons fait la même
chose en 2011 lorsque nous avons détruit
le régime de Kadhafi j'estime que c'est
la plus grave erreur de politique
étrangère de la 5e République
et parce que non seulement nous avons
mis un chaos qui n'est toujours pas
résolu en Libye mais nous avons mis un
chaos dans tous ces pays du celte qui
étaient nos amis et chaos qui est que
nous avons essayé de résoudre on fait
une deuxième guerre c'était barkhane
pour essayer de réparer les dégâts de la
première l'Afrique un peu plus tard et
donc là effectivement on a un petit peu
perdu
l'originalité
du jugement français si vous voulez
alors aujourd'hui il y a aussi autre
chose qui est important dans cette
diplomatie c'est qu'on essaye c'est que
le président en tout cas Macron a essayé
d'être honnesse broker d'être
intermédiaire sincère dans différentes
crises il faut reconnaître qu'il a pas
eu de chance que j'en ai quatre qui me
viennent en tête
faut pas marcher il y a l'Iran ça n'a
pas marché il y a l'Ukraine Russie ça
n'a pas marché il y a la Libye et
plusieurs conférences sur alibi à Paris
ça n'a pas marché et puis il y a le
Liban ça marche toujours pas
mais bon quand on voit quand on voit les
briques les pays émergents s'élargir à
de nouveaux membres à six nouveaux
membres
ne pas accepter apparemment la présence
d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait que l'Élysée
avait souhaité mais il n'a pas été
considéré comme le bienvenu est-ce que
justement on n'est pas un peu limité
dans nos ambitions de de nouer des
partenariats et de parler à tout le
monde
je dirais pas ça parce que de manière
générale
on a encore une grande ressource dans la
diplomatie française c'est la créativité
et on le voit d'ailleurs à ne pas le
plaisir
le président de la République lance
beaucoup d'initiatives mais certainement
pas un peu trop d'ailleurs alors ça
c'est une autre question mais prenez par
exemple à la récente conférence avant
l'été sur le financement futur des pays
des pays en voie de développement enfin
des pays africains pour dire les choses
simplement ça prend ça intéresse les
gens ils trouvent que c'est pas mal que
la France s'intéresse à ça essaye de
pousser un peu tout le monde dans ce
sens toute la question c'est bien
évidemment la suite qui est donnée à
cela sur le dossier particulier des
briques je pense qu'il faut un peu
attendre le jury est encore dehors et on
verra parce que autant le G7 a pris
comme une mayonnaise prend et devenue un
vrai lieu où des décisions importantes
peuvent être prises des actions peuvent
être menées les briques c'est encore une
une addition de pays qui souvent de
s'entendent même pas entre eux
donc c'est un peu de l'affichage pour
moi il y a un peu un affichage sous
l'influence en particulier de la Chine
et de la Russie du camp des antioxydants
et ça ça marche pendant un moment sauf
que à mon avis le monde est devenu
tellement le monde multipolaire est
devenu tellement complexe chacun des
grands acteurs a tellement d'intérêts
différents les uns des autres et
pratiques avant tout une politique
d'opportuniste que les lois d'être sûr
que ce Brix annonceront ils essaient de
se fixer une ou deux priorités ce que
l'on appelle la
dolarisation de l'économie mais il faut
pouvoir le faire l'Europe même avec
l'euro à essayer de trouver une une
monnaie qui puisse être une concurrence
du dollar et on sait pas aller très très
loin jusqu'à maintenant la semaine
prochaine Emmanuel Macron ira new de lhi
qu'est-ce qu'il devrait dire pour donner
corps donner de la substance à ces
déclarations de la semaine dernière
qu'elle devrait être sa posture au G20
je pense que la difficulté qui est qui
est la sienne c'est que tout le monde
comprend que les grandes questions sont
liées à l'agenda global c'est-à-dire le
réchauffement climatique les enjeux de
reconstruction d'un système financier la
perte de la biodiversité etc etc qui de
fait structure l'agenda présidentiel de
plus en plus mais celui-là et celui-ci
pardon est perturbé par des crises à
répétition et en particulier venant de
zones je pense on va venir vous l'avez
indiqué au Sahel ou la France pensait au
fond contribuer à la stabilité et en
fait elle se retrouve dans une dans une
situation où elle est rejetée du moins
dans du moins dans le discours de dans
le discours de certains et donc je pense
que pour lui c'est très difficile de
continuer à pousser ce qu'il fait depuis
2017 et ce qui est un des grands succès
de la diplomatie française pour moi le
dernier grand succès diplomatie
française est antérieure à l'arrivée
d'Emmanuel Macron sait ce sont pardon
les accords de Paris sur le climat en
2015 c'est-à-dire qui ont
l'ensemble de la diplomatie en marche
par rapport à l'agenda global mais tout
ça étant en fait très perturbé par de la
gestion de crise qui affaiblit les
positions de la France et
pointe un certain nombre de
contradictions pour tout dire dans notre
discours
Sylvie Berman oui pour revenir déjà au
G7 ça n'avait pas tellement de sens
d'aller au G7 et en réalité son idée
c'est où j'ai cette part au sommet des
briques
parce que son idée c'est de convaincre
tous ces pays que il ne faut pas
soutenir la Russie en fait c'est assez
occidentale un peu de ces pays là
absolument mais je pense que ça ne
fonctionne pas quand on explique à tous
ces pays que la Russie est née ou
colonialiste et que son intervention en
Ukraine est une intervention
néo-coloniale c'est totalement inaudible
dans tous ces pays et puis c'était le
moment de l'élargissement donc ces
réfléchissait à ce sujet mais c'est
quand même un signe de leur succès ce
n'était pas le cas auparavant là bon il
y a six nouveaux adhérents mais il y en
avait près de 40 qui étaient candidats
et parce que leur vision du monde
aujourd'hui c'est un monde qui est
effectivement multipolaire ça a été le
révélateur de la guerre en Ukraine et
ils ne veulent plus dépendre d'un ou
deux partenaires ils ne veulent plus
recevoir de leçons et se définir en
fonction de leurs intérêts et il y a un
nouveau thème qu'ils utilisent c'est la
le multi alignement et effectivement si
avec des États-Unis comme elle aura des
relations avec la Russie avec la Chine
c'est ça le Nouveau Monde c'est à dire
c'est d'abord cette fracture quand même
entre la Chine et les États-Unis et puis
effectivement des puissances émergentes
qui ont envie d'exister et de pas
s'aligner
Emmanuel Macron vis-à-vis de la Russie
il a essayé plusieurs rôles d'abord le
Onet broker je lis ça n'a pas marché
même le 7 février
2022 à Moscou la grande table de 5
mètres voilà avec la foutine ça n'a pas
marché bon alors ensuite il a essayé un
petit peu puis ensuite il s'est
complètement donc rallier au camp je
dirais americano polonais donc là
maintenant ça continue de la une
conversation téléphonique je croyais ou
aujourd'hui avec Zelinski et la France
va faire encore donc mais toute son
effort industriel derrière l'Ukraine en
guerre donc contre la Russie mais en
même temps on demande alors qu'on fait
la guerre à la Russie par novataire on
demande à être allé à une conférence
d'une d'un organisme qui a été fondé par
Poutine parce que les briques c'était
fondé par Poutine c'est une idée russe
au départ c'est ça marche pas si vous
voulez donc là effectivement il a un
petit flou et puis à courir aussi
plusieurs lèvres ou trop de lièvre à la
fois
on sait plus très bien après lequel on
court
j'ai assisté à cette conférence des
ambassadeurs à l'Élysée le président de
la République a cité 40 forums
internationaux différents 40 vous
avouerez Philippe que là à la fin
j'étais complètement noyé mais justement
est-ce que le paradoxe c'est pas que
alors c'est peut-être un trait commun à
beaucoup de président mais est-ce que ce
président là est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il l'écoute ces diplomates
question piège question piège oui et non
mais je veux dire quand vous écoutant je
pensais est-ce que les précédents
écouter exactement
pas pas sûr et c'est la vocation du
diplomate a prêcher un peu dans le
désert toujours des problèmes des
diplomates si vous comparez avec les
grands prédécesseurs c'est aujourd'hui
d'avoir le courage de de dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont l'un des problèmes
pour moi fondamentaux de la diplomatie
moderne c'est de faire la bonne analyse
de la situation d'avoir la lucidité de
comprendre ce qui se passe que les
Occidentaux comprennent qui n'ont plus
le monopole du pouvoir que le monde est
en train de changer comme ça a été dit
de tout côté et manuel Macron a l'air de
l'avoir bien mesuré problème c'est quand
vous passez de cette prise de conscience
là à l'action et au fond la manière dont
les diplomaties occidentales au-delà
même de la France se comporte se
confondant l'action elle continue à
faire comme avant c'est-à-dire que quand
on dit il faut un nouvel ordre mondial
et bien les Occidentaux disent on va
vous la recette on va vous dire comment
il faut faire alors qu'il faudrait
commencer par écouter les autres et leur
dire et les obliger aussi à prendre leur
responsabilité parce que c'est pas
facile mais de leur dire au fond
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire il y a
un point pour revenir à la question que
vous posiez tout à l'heure à Renault en
quoi la France a été originale et là je
pense que Sylvie ne me démentira pas
c'est la France a été un des premiers
pays un des premiers des 5 membres
permanents à dire qu'il fallait ouvrir
le Conseil de sécurité de nouveaux pays
c'était pas par altruisme c'est parce
que c'était notre siège qui était avec
celui de la Grande-Bretagne tout à
l'heure la gouvernance mais on n'est pas
prêt quand même à renoncer à notre
fauteuil permanent renoncer mais c'est
un ajouter d'autres membres permanents
va mettre un véto à l'entrée de l'Arche
et que donc il y aura jamais de
changement sauf que ça change pour moi
le vrai problème c'est que la France a
dit ça très tôt c'était assez
intéressant la Grande-Bretagne la
rejoint or de mon point de vue ça n'a
pas eu beaucoup d'impact sur les pays
non occidentaux c'est-à-dire qui nous
ont ils nous ont jamais vraiment
remercier pour cette position là et
c'est là où il y a peut-être un travail
un peu plus actif et agile à mener
non je pense que sincèrement on souhaite
un élargissement du Conseil de sécurité
parce qu'on est une puissance moyenne et
qu'on veut pas que notre siège soit
remis en cause un jour donc les
puissances assez conservatrices qui
étaient les États-Unis la Chine et la
Russie étaient opposés aujourd'hui je
pense que la Chine et la Russie verrait
un intérêt parce que les pays qui
rentreraient sont le Brésil le l'Inde
c'est-à-dire des pays qui sont pas sur
alignés sur sur Washington mais on
jouait enfin je dis on jouait parce que
aujourd'hui le Conseil de sécurité est
paralysé à cause du véto russe mais on
joue un rôle très important et 70% des
résolutions présentées à New York l'été
souvent par la France ou conjointement
par la France et par le Royaume-Uni donc
on avait un peu c'est pour ça que je
parlais de statut un rôle qui nous
permettait comme ça a été dit souvent de
boxer au dessus de notre catégorie alors
je voudrais qu'on en vienne au moyen et
on va voir une carte avec le réseau
diplomatique français
s'afficher Thomas Gomart ce réseau c'est
le réseau d'une grande puissance ou d'un
pays qui se prend pour une grande
puissance n'est ce pas on est à 162
ambassade sans compter celle de
l'Afghanistan qui a été rapatrié à Paris
il y en a deux qui sont fermés je crois
Yémen Siri à cause de la guerre 92
consulats généraux 27 représentations
permanentes auprès des organisations
internationales on se prend pour une
grande puissance toujours mais non mais
c'est un atout absolument considéré mais
il faut rappeler que
c'était tout s'est construit avec le
temps et que depuis 30 ans et je ne suis
pas diplomate donc peut-être que je peux
en parler c'est pour ça que je vous le
pose la question à vous facilement que
que Pierre et Sylvie vous avez eu une
érosion continue des crédits du Quai
d'Orsay depuis 30 ans et il faut reconn
peut être Emmanuel Macron deux choses
c'est que c'est le premier à relancer la
dépense militaire en 2017 et que c'est
le premier à relancer le crédit du Quai
d'Orsay et en fait la je crois que là il
n'est difficulté de la France c'est pas
seulement la question de positionnement
c'est aussi une question de moyens
c'est-à-dire que quand vous avez un tel
réseau mais que vous ne pouvez pas
forcément le faire vivre comme il
devrait ou l'alimenter comme il devrait
bien vous créez une image un peu
déceptive et puis je crois que la grande
différence aussi le grand problème qui
dépasserait largement la question
diplomatique c'est l'état économique de
la France c'est-à-dire que quand vous
êtes un pays perclus de dette avec 3000
milliards de dettes publiques et que
vous prétendez un carner une troisième
voie et ben on vous regarde avec un
certain scepticisme parce que ce que
vous avez à offrir est en réalité
surtout des mots
de grandes politiques étrangères de
Gaulle avait compris si on n'a pas de
l'ordre chez soi c'est-à-dire de Gaulle
commence de Gaulle quand il arrive il
fait le plan Armand Ruf donc il rétablit
les finances publiques et ensuite il
fait la décolonisation c'est à dire il
s'occupe de de l'Algérie mais qui était
quand même des départements français etc
et c'est seulement après qui commence sa
grande politique étrangère je dirais
qu'elle commence à terre de 64 avec le
voyage d'amour en Amérique latine si
vous voulez mais il a remis le pays en
ordre et le pays fait l'admiration de
toute l'Europe parce qu'il marche très
bien la France et vous avez beau avoir
les meilleures idées du monde mais quand
vous avez une pagaille noire dans vos
finances publiques quand vous avez pris
un engagement international de dire que
jamais au grand jamais c'est une idée
française les 60% maximum de dettes et
que vous êtes à 115% de votre partenaire
voilà les critères les critères de
maastrisme quand vous quand le niveau de
votre de système scolaire ne cesse de
dégringoler quand vous avez des vrais
problèmes de sécurité dans les villes
nous emmener un peu loin renommer voilà
on a bien compris voilà ce que je veux
dire c'est que on ne peut rayonner et on
ne peut être écouté même si on a les
meilleurs idées du monde que si le pays
va bien on donne l'exemple chez soi
c'est comme si il y a 10 ans le Premier
ministre de la Grèce voulait très
intelligent vous l'expliquez toutes les
relations internationales au monde
entier on l'aurait pas écouté voilà
c'est tout
vous alliez couper Renaud je pense qu'il
a raison on a un problème d'image et
quand il y a des émeutes à Paris quand
il y a ce problème de sécurité plus les
sujets économiques qui ont été
mentionnés on est plus aussi attractif
que qu'on l'était auparavant alors c'est
vrai dans les pays autoritaires puisque
de toute façon on pense qu'on a un
modèle qui est supérieur selon la
formule de ce Churchill la démocratie et
le père des systèmes d'exception de tous
les autres aujourd'hui la démocratie ne
fait plus rêver dans ces pays-là après
le
Capitole et puis tous ces mouvements
dans nos pays et ça on en est pas
conscient on a raison de défendre la
démocratie on a raison de défendre nos
valeurs mais on a plus de mal à
convaincre qu'autrefois est-ce que
l'outil et cette carte qu'on a montré
est-ce que l'outil est adapté à la
mission aux missions pierrevillon est-ce
qu'il est surdimensionné est-ce qu'il
est sous-dimensionné il y a combien
13600 agents au ministère des Affaires
étrangères il est il est un même à
certains égards je dirais indispensable
à condition comme le disait très
justement top regardez le Royaume-Uni à
148 postes l'Allemagne 145 nous 162
faisons pas forcément des politiques
étrangères plus brillantes que la nôtre
tout dépend de ce que vous en faites pas
forcément moins brillante non plus
peut-être tout dépend de ce que vous
faites de votre réseau lorsque je
travaillais au cabinet de Dominique de
Villepin il m'avait justement fixé comme
comme ligne de conduite ne fermons pas
d'ambassade parce que c'est un de nos
vrais outils et à l'époque je vous donne
un exemple comme on a pratiquement des
ambassades dans tous les petits pays
d'Amérique centrale tout le monde au
Quai d'Orsay disait il faut fermer etc
regrouper peut-être dans une
condambassade qui aurait été au Costa
Rica pour s'occuper du Honduras et du
Salvador or quand vous allez dans ces
pays-là et que vous leur dites désolé
mais on va fermer notre ambassade c'est
fini pour notre influence et notre
prestige dans ce pays là on se coupe à
tout jamais d'interlocuteurs donc il
faut être conscient de ça il faut
peut-être trouver de nouvelles modalités
pour organiser nos ambassades dans ces
dans ces pays de moindre dimension mais
il faut être la présence est
indispensable dans les deux sens la
présence pour écouter ce que les autres
nous dire et la présence pour connaître
ces pays et faire comprendre à Paris à
l'administration centrale
quelles sont les problèmes de ces
pays-là sinon en effet ça ne sert à rien
mais du coup on a plus d'écoute on ne
comprend plus ce qui se passe dans le
monde et c'est là où nous ambassade sont
indispensables est-ce que l'outil est
assez moderne
la diplomatie ne projette pas
nécessairement une image de grande
modernité et saint Thor et enfin est-ce
que c'est une perception erronée dans ma
Goma je suis dans une position où
j'interagis beaucoup avec à la fois
évidemment la diplomatie française et
puis d'autres diplomaties la nôtre a pas
du tout à rougir et je pense qu'elle
attire des gens de très grandes valeurs
qui effectivement se heurte aux limites
des moyens il y a eu une grève l'année
dernière qui est aboutit qui entraînait
les états généraux de la diplomatie qui
était tout un travail à mon avis dont la
mise en oeuvre est très importante
c'est-à-dire que si pour le rapport
c'était réarmé la diplomatie mais la
question en fait est celle là c'est à
dire que c'est pas tellement la question
du réseau tel que vous l'avez montré
c'est plutôt que ces états généraux la
diplomatie vont aboutir à une
amélioration sensible si vous voulez
quand tant quand vous avez désinvestis
pendant 30 ans c'est très difficile de
remonter ça explique à mon avis beaucoup
de nos soucis en Afrique c'est-à-dire
qu'on a abandonné des problèmes de
coopération qui fonctionnent très bien
et on les remplace effectivement par un
par des sommets 40 sommets comme le
rappeler Renault au fond par des effets
de communication qui masquent à mon sens
le désinvestissement sur des pans
entiers de coopération
c'est pas très bien compris alors il
faut peut-être attendre effectivement le
jury est peut-être encore
dehors c'est pas très bien compris la
réforme de l'ENAC en est pas vraiment
une fin c'est le mec en quelques mots
pour nous et la réforme surtout il y
avait il y avait un changement de statut
professionnel des des diplomates et là
on l'impression mais j'ai demandé à
plusieurs diplomates et personne n'a
vraiment compris la réforme c'est normal
voilà personne n'a vraiment compris
c'est tellement c'est ce qu'on comprend
pas c'est ce qu'elle apporte on comprend
ce qu'elle retire parce qu'elle retire
c'est dire c'est à dire un corps de
diplomate professionnel on a parlé par
exemple des pays des pays de l'Est c'est
quand même très important dans tous ces
pays que ce soit au Kazakhstan ou en
Russie ou ailleurs précisément de parler
le russe quoi parce que c'est comme ça
que vous vous pouvez vraiment
dans les pays arabes de parler l'arabe
mais
et j'ai l'impression que on a détruit
des corps qui existaient il y avait des
recrutements pour les conseillers des
secrétaires d'Orient je crois que ça m'a
maintenant ça va être mêlée avec Léna
c'est pas encore complètement
mais mais on a eu l'impression que
pour Emmanuel Macron tout le monde
pouvait tout faire dans l'état si vous
voulez qu'un administrateur de l'État il
pouvait à la fois un jour être
misériculture un jour à Bercy et un jour
dans la diplomatie je crois
personnellement que la diplomatie exe
est exige un peu d'expérience et de
métier quand je quand je parlais de la
modernité tout à l'heure j'avais en tête
les les opérations de propagande
auxquelles dont nous sommes parfois la
cible est-ce que les diplomates sont
formés à faire ce type de travail
d'influence de contre propagande je
crois que la question est plus générale
c'est ce que pour reprendre
l'expression de Sylvie tout à l'heure
est-ce que les diplomaties sont la
meilleure manière sans la bonne est-ce
que les démocraties savent répondre à la
désinformation parce que c'est pas un
problème de formation des diplomates
c'est un problème de je crois que c'est
un vrai problème et on le voit je vois
là où j'ai travaillé avant dans le
service diplomatique à Bruxelles où ils
ont créé une cellule contre le
contre-information les messages qu'ils
inventent tous les jours et qu'ils
envoient sont sur le réseau soyons
clairs c'est un infantilisme et d'une
assez grande médiocrité qui fait rire
même ceux qui les écrivent personne n'y
croit vraiment face aux
en ce moment en Afrique les
manifestations les slogans contre la
France finalement c'est bon cercle
terreau est favorable mais quand même
quelque chose c'est pas ça qui est à la
base c'est pas c'est pas l'influence
russe qui est à la base des échecs
actuels de notre de notre politique
africaine c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus ancien et plus deuxièmement la
seule bonne réponse à la désinformation
russe c'est par exemple ce qu'on a été
capable de faire par rapport aux
opérations abominables de l'armée
libyenne soutenue par Wagner qui a fait
qui a fait des tueries abominables dans
le nord du pays qui a essayé de les
imputer à la France grâce aux
informations qu'on avait on a pu
démanteler ça
des contre des informations de contrôle
c'est par ce travail là il est il est il
est compliqué et simplement de sa
demande du temps et on n'est pas
toujours sur le coup mais vous
n'arriverez jamais à contrecarrer les
usines à trolls qui tous les jours
déversent par l'intermédiaire
d'organisation russe ou autre tout ce
discours anti-français et de manière
générale aussi occidental il me semble
qu'on perde beaucoup d'énergie à vouloir
essayer de contrecarrer ça
l'Afrique juste un mot sur l'Afrique je
pense qu'on a il nous manque un
instrument alors là parce qu'on a
détruit le ministère de la Coopération
il connaissait bien l'Afrique je dois
aussi lui d'accord avec moi et aussi on
a pas une cellule africaine très forte à
l'Élysée donc on avait deux deux outils
auparavant qui fonctionnait bien et
aujourd'hui
parfois trop bien la cellule africaine
de l'Élysée
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors quand on est
confronté à une situation comme celle
par prenant l'exemple du Niger puisqu'on
a un ambassadeur qui est quand même
retranché dans son ambassade qui dort
avec son gilet pare-balles ou à peu près
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ces cas-là
quelqu'un a une suggestion
vous avez géré ce genre de crise oui
mais la bonne attitude d'abord de
maintenir cette ambassadeur au nom des
principes au nom des principes tels
qu'ils ont été développés depuis début
par la France ça a du sens de le
maintenir c'est un peu en dépit des
réalités aussi oui bien sûr mais je
tiens dans une situation extrêmement
complexe comme celle-là il faut il faut
trouver des des
compromis possibles et essayer de
trouver la manière de sortir de ça il me
semble que l'une des seuls solutions
pour le moment serait d'encourager par
tous les moyens notamment à travers des
médiateurs africains que les deux
parties se parlent c'est à dire que on
puisse enfin entamer un dialogue entre
le président bassum et l'agent
directement
je sais que c'est très compliqué mais
c'est probablement la seule solution il
faut peut-être du temps et il faut
surtout éviter pendant ce temps là en
gardant d'une manière d'une autre des
canaux de communication entre les uns et
les autres c'est d'éviter que l'une ou
l'autre des deux parties n'aillent trop
loin et ne se mettent à prendre des
initiatives qui deviendraient très
dangereuses vis-à-vis de notre ambassade
et notre ambassadeur
sans arrêt si vous voulez on a vu
Olivier Véran je sais pas ce qu'il
connaît à l'Afrique condamné le coup
d'État les paroles du gouvernement
condamné le coup d'État au Gabon et
juste après la diplomatie française a
commencé à rétropédaler au vu au-dessus
de tout le monde moi j'ai trouvé tout à
fait fâcheux que notre ministre des
Affaires étrangères dans un interview à
RFI autour du 6 août et menacé les
dirigeants les généraux puccistes
nigériens bien sûr que la France
[Musique]
l'échec de la France en Afrique comment
vous l'analysez parce que là on sent on
est vraiment dans une situation
assez démunie quand même
oui
si vous voulez je pense qu'il s'explique
par une contradiction assez fondamentale
entre un discours de démocratisation
porté au fond depuis La Baule
et l'hésitation à assurer de la
sécurisation de régime pour justifier
une présence militaire française
ancienne qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
forcément remise en cause par les pays
en question je crois qu'il faut aussi
faire prendre garde de
en distinguant bien les situations la
situation évidemment n'est pas du tout
celle du Niger et que il y a aussi une
demande de ces pays là on se retrouve
cloué au pylori par le Mali mais
l'intervention de 2013 a été demandé par
les autorités maliennes et tous les pays
de la région
étaient en soutien la vraie question
qu'on doit se poser c'est en fait
pourquoi en 2017 lorsque Emmanuel Macron
veut quitter le Mali il n'arrive pas à
le faire et ça ça nous renvoie des
effets de système de notre propre
système militaire en particulier qui
mériterait peut-être d'être analysé
c'est très délicat à faire c'est un peu
comme sur la Libye je pense qu'il y a
des il y a un travail
ça peut aussi se justifier au regard de
l'histoire de la demande de de ces pays
ça se justifie aussi par le discours de
l'influence si vous voulez moi je crois
difficile de faire de l'influence sans
présence mais ça doit s'adapter c'est à
dire qu'il faut aussi comprendre que
cette modalité de présence
ces uniformes peut-être sont vécues
comme trop visibles dans ces sociétés de
moins en moins acceptées lesquelles sont
aussi complètement connectées à la
mondialisation et donc sont dans le flux
d'information c'est peut-être ça qu'on a
pas saisi en fait c'est de croire que
pouvait parler aux sociétés africaines
donc par exemple qu'on leur parle elles
sont elles-mêmes connectées je dirais à
la discussion globale laquelle est
soumise à ses effets je dirais
d'informations de désinformation que que
l'on a identifié donc mon point c'est de
dire il y a une difficulté très très
particulière qu'il faut qu'il faut
savoir traiter et là effectivement moi
je suis pas qualifié pour dire ce qu'il
faut faire au Niger concernant
l'ambassadeurs mais je pense qu'il faut
avoir une réflexion plus profonde sur
démocratie d'un côté et éléments de
sécurité à portée de l'autre voilà
est-ce que c'est fondamentalement
contradictoire comme certains essaient
de nous faire croire ou est-ce que ça
peut être conjugué
on va passer à une autre crise parce que
il y en a pas mal sur le notre écran
radar la Russie l'Ukraine Sylvie Berman
vous pensez qu'on a la bonne diplomatie
qu'on a fait des erreurs que
aujourd'hui on a on a plus tellement le
choix il y a un état agresseur un état
agressé et on l'aide à défendre ça
souveraineté le président de la
République a eu raison d'engager le
dialogue avec Vladimir Poutine jusqu'à
la crise du covid il y avait quand même
un peu de résultats puisque il avait
obtenu que
Poutine rencontre Elan ski à Paris il a
rencontré pour la première fois il y a
eu des accords il y a même eu des
accords sur le gaz bon normalement il y
avait un autre rendez-vous qui n'a
jamais eu lieu tout le monde enfermé
aussi avec cause du covid et quand
Emmanuel Macron a essayé et a essayé de
réactiver les accords de mine ce que
c'était trop tard la décision de de
Poutine était sûrement prise mais je
pense qu'il a eu raison de il a eu
raison d'essayer et bon
on en est aujourd'hui la diplomatie
c'est trop tôt pour en parler c'est trop
tôt c'est trop tôt je crois que Nicolas
Sarkozy au cours de l'été disant un peu
comme avant la guerre comme si elle
n'avait pas eu lieu que l'Ukraine devait
rester un pays neutre un trait d'union
je crois que maladroit plus jamais être
un trait d'union dans la mesure où elle
restera au style à la Russie pendant des
décennies ce qu'on peut comprendre aussi
maintenant bon appeler à la négociation
c'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
de choquant non plus après il faut voir
qu'elle semblerait la Turquie oui mais
la Turquie
c'est la Turquie d'abord elle est pas
membre de l'Union européenne même si
elle est membre de l'OTAN parfois on
peut se poser des questions mais non
elle a gardé cette liberté c'est à dire
que elle a soutenu l'Ukraine avec les
missiles barakta et en même temps elle a
refusé de sanctionner la Russie ce qui
lui permet de d'offrir un terrain neutre
entre guillemets pour des rencontres
puisque les premiers rencontres
diplomatiques entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine c'était tenu en Turquie et
bien évidemment la Turquie jouera un
rôle nous je pense que ce n'est plus
possible c'est à dire à un moment on
viendra à table de négociation la France
sera présente encore une fois aussi
parce qu'elle est membre permanente du
Conseil de sécurité mais c'est
malheureusement c'est le temps de la
guerre aujourd'hui et des offensives sur
le terrain si on gelait tout c'est un
peu une prime à l'agresseur ça veut dire
que la Russie qui occupe 17% du
territoire aurait des gains non
seulement territoriaux mais des gains
politiques quelles pourront être les
contours d'une solution diplomatique
vous les avez en tête pierre vivement
c'est très difficile de les avoir en
pour le moment parce que beaucoup
dépendra de du résultat sur le terrain
militaire sur le champ de bataille et de
la façon dont les dans le rapport de
force entre la Russie l'Ukraine et
évoluera mais je voulais juste revenir
une seconde sur la Russie la Russie est
typiquement la puissance opportuniste
par excellence qui a mené je dois le
dire d'ailleurs avec la Russie une
diplomatie extrêmement intelligente
puisque elle réussit à discuter avec un
pays
où dans toute une série de de de
conflits Cyril Libye elle est en
opposition directe militaire avec avec
la Russie et malgré cela ils arrivent à
se parler donc c'est quand même assez
intéressant et c'est un atout dont il
faut savoir peut-être utiliser comme on
le fait actuellement sur toute l'affaire
de de la Corse sur les céréales mais il
ne faut pas se leurrer pour la Russie le
seul interlocuteur qui comptera le jour
il faudra définit
sur sur l'Ukraine ce sont les États-Unis
c'est ce dialogue là qu'ils veulent
avoir et c'est pour ça que dans le
conflit actuel tel qu'il se développe ce
qui me paraît intéressant à observer
c'est l'attitude américaine dont on voit
bien qu'elle n'est plus tout à fait sur
la même ligne que Kiev que le ski
qu'elle a peut-être d'autres idées en
tête qu'elles voient lentement arriver
l'ombre de la campagne électorale aux
États-Unis avec les risques cela peut
avoir sur le dossier
ukrainien et par conséquent
l'attitude américaine est à observer de
très près et c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles la Russie
elle-même n'a aucune envie de négocier
n'oublions pas que d'abord
la débandade des Occidentaux
elle aussi et on voit mal suspense
qu'aux États-Unis mais on voit mal
Poutine lâcher quoi que ce soit avant
cette élection présidentielle ce serait
pas très bon pour sa cote de popularité
les élections américaines arrivent et
pour le moment sur le terrain une
situation qui ne l'aurait pas aussi
défavorable on pouvait l'espérer Thomas
Gomar l'impact de des débat politique
américain sur la cohésion des
Occidentaux
derrière l'Ukraine en soutien l'Ukraine
vous êtes préoccupé ou vous voyez des
nuages ça mentley ou pas je pense que
c'est l'horizon de la nuit à Poutine des
examen c'est parfaitement clair lui il
est Paris là dessus un peu oui parce que
il parie sur un retour de Donald Trump
ou d'un de ses avatars et en ce sens
effectivement
il a raison de faire de faire ce pari
moi ce qui me frappe je crois qu'on est
tous autour de la table tous une
expérience de la de la Russie et de
l'Ukraine des différentes mais ce qui
est quand même très frappant c'est
la régression russe c'est à dire que
voilà voilà un pays qui est en train de
reverser dans des formes de soviétisme
aiguë
de manière beaucoup plus rapide que ce à
quoi on
s'attendait qui s'est coupé de l'Europe
qui est en train de se mettre dans une
situation
d'objets pour pour la Chine dans les
années à venir et qui au fond est en
train de ruiner son pays enfin la Russie
aujourd'hui s'est mise dans une
situation d'elle-même d'abord d'échecs
militaires en Ukraine et de perspective
bloquée pour son développement mais elle
obtient de manière assez effectivement
habile
des rétributions diplomatiques à
l'extérieur et notamment en Afrique ce
qui est assez frappant dans la dans la
politique française pour faire un lien
c'est que évidemment il y a eu cette
tentative d'ouverture
de la part d'Emmanuel Macron vis-à-vis
de la Russie qui à mon avis ça c'est une
analyse personnelle je sais pas si elle
sera partagée mais très vite passé sur
2014 c'est à dire qu'on a pris
l'annexion de la Crimée comme quelque
chose d'assez secondaire alors qu'en
réalité c'était annonciateur à mon avis
de la volonté tout à fait construite de
la Russie de Vladimir Poutine de
détruire l'Union européenne beaucoup
plus que l'OTAN d'ailleurs et ce faisant
détruire l'Union européenne en tant que
entité politique je pense ce qui lui est
le plus insupportable c'est l'Union
européenne et ce faisant d'accepter un
comportement russe en Afrique qui s'est
retourné contre la France donc là il y a
effectivement à mon avis un problème
russe de la France sur la nyanise qui a
pu être faite différentes périodes un
2003 l'opposition commune à
l'intervention anglo-américaine en Irak
2008 qui est le pont d'Arcole du
président Sarkozy qui passe plus
rapidement sur 2011 et 2008 je pense les
conditions du retour de Vladimir Poutine
au Kremlin en 2012 et les manifestations
qu'elles avaient occasionné à l'époque
que l'on a regardé au fond comme là
aussi une facétie et puis 2014 la vraie
rupture c'est 2014 après le soutien qui
permet à Bachar el-Assad de revenir à la
Ligue arabe à Jedda en mai 2023 et donc
je pense qu'il y a de notre là aussi en
termes un peu de retour d'expérience
très probablement un travail à faire sur
pourquoi nous avons lu la réussite cette
manière moi
je ne crois pas que
Boutin et souhaité détruire
l'Union européenne il a eu comme un
dialogue constant avec un pilier de
cette union européenne qui était quand
même Angela Merkel et je me souviens
bien que Angela Merkel lorsqu'elle a
quitté le pouvoir est allé voir
personnellement à Moscou
Vladimir Poutine pour pour lui dire au
revoir et sans doute pour le remercier
de cette coopération en revanche c'est
tout à fait certain que Vladimir Poutine
n'a pas supporté la
la transition vers le temps des pays
baltes on se souvient du sénateur Joe
Biden côté réalisateur expliquant en
1999 on a une vidéo que ça serait une
provocation inadmissible à l'égard de la
Russie que de d'intégrer les Pays Basque
à l'OTAN et il y a une obsession
effectivement poutinienne de
là-dessus alors que la Russie par
ailleurs avait garanti par traité
la souveraineté territoriale de
l'Ukraine et donc il ne pouvait pas
supporter que l'Ukraine qui est dans
l'esprit des Russes a toujours été une
sorte de tampon vis-à-vis de l'Ouest que
ce tampon passe complètement du côté
ouest et équit la neutralité que la
Russie aurait aimé que que l'Ukraine
mais c'est dommage mais la diplomatie
française avait eu un grand succès avec
l'allemand de la Polonaise elle avait eu
obtenu un accord
ukrainien le 21 février à Kiev
2014 on avait vu le président prorus
yanukovic serrait la main des trois
leaders de l'opposition il y a de ces
newslichco est un ebook et alors là par
défaut de technique diplomatique on a on
est revenu chez soi après cet accord le
vendredi soir au lieu de plébisciter on
n'a pas on n'a pas poursuivi on n'a pas
fait le suivi et c'est à loupé
incroyable alors le dossier russe est un
très vaste et on en viendra pas au bout
mais je voudrais qu'on dit un mot quand
même des relations avec la Chine Sylvie
Berman est-ce que justement cette
relation d'équilibre au pluriel entre
une puissance moyenne comme la France et
la Chine est-ce que c'est pas sur ce
dossier là justement que ça peut
s'exprimer
cette espèce de non alignement avec avec
les États-Unis tout à fait mais je pense
que c'est effectivement la Chine qui
l'avait en tête pour ne pas être
entraîné dans
à tous les quatre pour cette
conversation très enrichissante pour ma
part je vous donne rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
bonne semaine à tous